when you're thinking about a product
launch first thing I would ask is is it
the right time to do product launch so
if your product isn't figured out if you
can't hold the orders now is not the
right time to be on TechCrunch once
you're in a major media outlet they're
not going to cover you again
for some period of time or ever if
you're in the business section the New
York Times they're not going to cover
you for weeks later when your product is
better and you're ready so make sure
that you pick your timings so there's
paid exposure and unpaid exposure I like
to focus on unpaid because it forces you
to make better decisions in the
beginning so I would read as I always
say the 22 immutable laws of marketing
1,000 true fans written by Kevin Kelly I
would also read best-selling book PR and
publicity I think it is all of the
techniques apply to more than books and
learn to tell the story what are you
focusing on are you using yourself to
tell the story and then the product is
associated is it a trend piece are you
trying to tie what you're doing into a
greater trend which is very effective
way of getting media in which case
you're going to need other examples you
need to get comfortable bringing in sort
of cooperative competitors to create
that trend base learn the art of the
pitch and of messaging only once you
have figured that out what I say then
you go out and you pay to acquire people
because now if your messaging is off
it's costing you money I only invest in
things that I understand and things that
I use or would use myself this is really
really really important anytime I step
outside of that is usually when the
universe kicks me in the nuts really
hard and I lose my money I think it's
it's critical to as an entrepreneur
scratch your own itch it increases the
odds of success or the probability of
success and then it's as an investor I
look for people who are scratching their
own ass you just watch - amazing clips
from Tim Ferriss take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]